yes so we had a short statement
previously yesterday from lord guy now
we've got the full letter i'm literally
reading this for the first time um but i
think if you go towards a sort of fourth
paragraph he says this week however i
was tasked to offer a view about the
government's intention to consider
measures which risk a deliberate and
purposeful breach of the ministerial
code this request has placed me in an
impossible and odious position my
informal response on monday was that you
and any other minister should justify
open uh opening your position vis-a-vis
the code in such circumstances however
the idea that a prime minister might
to any degree be in the business of
deliberately breaching his own code is
an affront a deliberate breach or even
an intention to do so
should
uh would be to suspend the provisions of
the code to suit a political end this
would make a mockery not only of the
respect of the code but licence a
suspension of its provisions in
governing the conduct of her majesty's
minister ministers i can have no part in
this so um just reading this now but i
think that makes clear that he felt
the prime minister he said a deliberate
and purposeful breach of the ministerial
code there was a risk of that from what
he was tasked with doing
and this would make a mockery he says
not only of respect for the code but
license the suspension of its provisions
in governing her majesty's ministers i
can have no part in so clearly he felt
he was being asked to do something
that he thought breached the minister's
code
he of course was the ethics advisor
their second ethics advisor that boris
johnson has lost there were questions
swirling before we had this uh letter
today about why he had decided to go we
he was before
mps earlier this week and um now he has
written this letter he when he was
before mps he said
that he
felt this was a blunt tool
resigning one of the only tools left to
an ethical advice ethics advisor but um
now he has decided that this is the
moment to go and that is i think a very
strongly worded letter from a supposedly
mild mannered man he says that it would
make a mockery of the ministerial code
and worth saying i've also just been
given a response from boris johnson who
said that he is sorry to receive the
letter of resignation yesterday thanks
him for his service um he said that on
monday he'd said that he was content to
remain until the end of the year so this
letter has come as a surprise the prime
minister says and then he goes on at the
end to say that he's carried out his
duties
admirably but he also says that when he
says he was put in an impossible
position regarding my seeking of your
advice on potential future decisions
related to the trade remedies authority
so this is clearly um what this issue
has been about and worth saying this
morning dominic robb had said that there
had been a commercially sensitive matter
in the national interest and clearly
this has been the straw that has broken
the camel's back and led to lord geit
resigning
so we have the full letter i think from
what we've seen so far it is pretty
strongly worded clear
that this was him feeling he couldn't
carry on in his role given um what was
happening in government earlier today
william rag quoted oscar wilde saying
that to lose one ethics advisor might be
deemed a misfortune to lose two looks
like carelessness and i think um that
quote might be echoed over parliament
today mps i spoke to yesterday thought
that the timing and nature this short
statement meant that it wouldn't shift
the dial necessarily but this letter is
pretty strongly worded could this shift
the dial for some members of prime
minister boris johnson